let's talk about this story do you see
this uh you see the protests breaking
out in Tennessee over the over the masks
in schools all these parents showed up
yeah I saw a clip of it this morning
they're screaming you're you know
there's a special place in hell for you
we know where you we we will find you we
know where you live wow you know what's
really crazy about this stuff first I'll
say a couple things we have the story
from CNN
School masturbate Tennessee grows heated
as local board requires masks in
elementary schools what's interesting is
that Steve Bannon told us this he said
come August 15th when parents see what
these schools are doing to their kids
the moms are going to come out and all
hell will break loose something that
effect paraphrasing and it wasn't just
critical race applied principles it
wasn't just the masses all of these
things and now it's August 12th and
we're seeing parents screaming at these
people
so I think Steve was right about that I
think it'll be interesting to see what
happens in in the next couple of weeks
with schools coming back in full swing
and parents being like nah none of this
but the crazy thing about it is
these school boards
that are voting to have mass mandates
while there are 100 or so parents
outside screaming insults and and you
know we know where you live veiled
threats
why are they voting in favor of that
yeah I don't know these parents will
have a long memory too they are not
going to let this go if they do
something to harm their kids mental
health like we saw that last year uh
with the mass mandates and and just the
policies that they put in place in these
schools depression went way up anxiety
went up Suicide Hotline calls went way
up suicide rates have crept up
um they they are harming their kids to a
lot of in a lot of parents opinions not
all some people think that it's
protecting their kids which is why we
cannot have a shared reality right now
apparently uh so they are not they're
not going to let this go Tim you know
what you know what you know what these
people don't understand and I
so I'm 35 right
the day time moves much more quickly as
you get older they say and it's mostly
because things become routine at least
this is my view of it when I wake up and
have breakfast and same breakfast over
and over again I might I don't have a
strong memory of the breakfast I had
because the same breakfast I had 100
times I'm older a lot of my experiences
are routine and forgettable but the
first time you wrote a train I remember
the first time I would train I remember
the first time I flew in a plane because
those were like things in my life I'd
never done before when you're younger
you're 10 years old
a day is a lot longer percentage-wise of
your life
so imagine a year of not being able to
go outside go to the park go play with
your friends it's like putting these
kids in solitary confinement I know a
guy and his son committed suicide
he was 12 because of the lockdown and
then his dad came out and started doing
advocacy saying like we can't do this to
our kids man you're an adult maybe you
don't mind sitting in your lounge chair
and relaxing and working from home but
these kids are trying to to experience
life and it's being stripped away from
them if you're ten ten percent of your
life was in solitary basically 10
percent
for me
one Thirty fifth of my life was spent
with a lockdown and I'm I'm older and
I'm working on a company I've had the
experience I've traveled the world I've
hung out with my friends I've gone
skateboarding and now I'm like working
from home building a business these kids
they want to go out they want to explore
well I think the narrative needs to be
switched on his head uh these children
have a right to their childhood they
have a right to see smiling people they
have the right to live in a pleasant
environment they have a and we're
talking about the formative years so it
is really Beyond a doubt and you know I
was a psych Department assistant I I
listened you know I'm immersed in all of
psychology and childhood development and
so forth you are stunning their
psychosocial development it's really not
even debatable it's it's just a fact if
you take away the right to read you know
the ability of children to read emotions
or to feel comfort and to see uh smiling
faces and reassurance that you're
basically it's kind of like the that old
video the wall from Pink Floyd you know
you're just creating like this Factory
of faceless uh you know uh and Anonymous
just sort of uh you know you're
dehumanizing them you're alienating them
you're atomizing them and this for me it
strikes me as a political program it's
not it's the children are not in from
what I've seen the research Wall Street
Journal you can go uh just look at it
they're not appreciably at risk for this
thank God it's one of the Small Miracles
that we can point to during this
pandemic and we're not taking advantage
of it that it used to be in society
where adults were wanting to be on the
front lines they wanted to Bear the
brunt of things they wanted to protect
their children
um at all costs and now we're seeing
from what I perceive as a lot of anxiety
and hysteria and selfishness on the
point of parents who just refuse to
protect their children their childhood I
mean
they're they're project they're so
selfish and narcissistic they're
projecting their own anxiety onto their
own child and for me that just shows a
lack of empathy and ability to put
yourself in another person's shoes it's
a real social Scourge right now I posted
simply an image from statista of covid
deaths by age group right I said nothing
made no comment screenshot post
some establishment type Democrat
activist
took the screen grabbed circled like
circled the elderly and then said Tim
Poole doesn't care that these people are
going to die and I'm like I literally
said nothing I literally had no comment
on the data other than like I just
posted the data like here's some
information for you nice it shows you
the weakness that they're they're
concerned about the the largest group at
risk are people who are over 65 there is
a decent risk for people over 40 and the
risk diminishes for people who are under
40. uh I believe it's like 1.63 percent
of deaths were under 40. close yeah and
uh 30 according to the CDC of people
hospitalized were obese so it's much
more than that I read when it was 78
that CDC said they had obesity but that
is one study it probably it probably
varies it probably varies CDC webs it's
just the headline yeah 30.2 of
hospitalizations over the past since the
start of the pandemic was was obesity
okay 94 comorbidities so I think
understanding all the context having
that information when you go to your
doctor and talk to them about what makes
sense for you and be being healthy take
care of yourself Eat Right be right be
well all that good stuff 94 of the
people hospitalized by government have
had co-order of death that's right CDC
says that yeah right so in other words
1.6 average of people with
cardiopulmonary diseases lung disease
diabetes
Etc which is morbidity yeah and so so
it's older people yeah so there are
plausible causes of death and they
happen to test positive for covid as
well so they're not trying to do a
diagnosis of a cause of death
necessarily but they're saying I will I
will stress too A lot of people think
that the 94 comorbidity means they
didn't die from covid but the way right
the way to describe it is like imagine
you have a bridge that's been old and
dilapidated and then someone jumps up
and down on it like the covet is the
jumping up and down like Well yeah if
you didn't do that the bridge probably
would have been fine so you get you get
something like covet and look we've had
a lot of people on this show
uh conservatives who have either been
vaccinated or have gotten coveted and it
it sounds bad yeah I I I I we have we've
talked to some people on the show I
don't want to out the people who have
you know experienced bad sicknesses but
we've had people who are like dude it
was miserable like two weeks of fatigue
yeah you get that with those shots too
though I mean I had the modern around a
couple of those and uh yeah it wiped me
for a couple of weeks so but but the
thing for this that we want to do we
want to introduce it to all of our
troops for me that is too risky these
These are young athletic you know
physically fit people who are not
necessarily at risk that much uh it's
it's very similar to seasonal flu if you
look at the statistics for that
particular age group 20 to 30 and I
think it's very I think you'd wait until
all yeah but there's results come in to
make that decision so I think they
should be very careful about that
because I definitely agree with being
careful I definitely think the challenge
here is I I hope that they go on an
individual basis is the important thing
because of potential underlying
conditions but at the same time
I mean if we've got people that have to
go into conflict and deploy and go in
areas it would be nightmarish if there
was an outbreak of covid of of any
illness really my understanding was that
you know people who want to go through
basic they get a bunch of vaccines
absolutely yeah so I agree I think we
got to be really careful right now
simply because uh we need FDA approval
for sure we need to make sure we're
doing right by all of the science and
without even fauci saying the science
changes as as we learn more it's like
okay well like let's make sure if it's
our military we're going to be extra
careful to make sure that we have the
capability to defend ourselves and our
allies and you know just I'm just
wondering if the vaccine could harm
even metabolism or you know to have some
sort of lingering effects it is possible
that it could cause some sort of
reaction and I mean because you're
intentionally stimulating the immune
system to have a response against an
antigen but that's that's tricky that is
true but uh this is something that
Charlie Kirk brought up when we were on
the debate with Voss she mentioned gilan
baray syndrome and he said that the the
you know uh CDC has put out a nerve
damage warning for the Johnson Johnson
vaccine that that side effect actually
is for many other vaccines as well so
you know I went to the CDC a few years
ago uh this was during I think zika and
I did an interview because we were you
know we were just trying to find some
like interesting stories and it was
around the time the division came out
you ever played that game I didn't play
the division awesome game by the way and
it's basically like the world is a
post-pandemic apocalyptic scenario and
so I was like let's go do an interview
with the CDC and ask them about their um
I forgot it was called it was like
operation something where they simulated
a large-scale pandemic and it was really
interesting and what I was told there by
some of the people at the CDC was
there are risks for vaccines and side
effects they're they're well known
they're on the cdc's website make sure
you read that stuff and talk to your
doctor because you could be in that that
small percentage group they said the
challenges were for a lot of these
diseases if there's like
we're expecting to get 200 000 deaths
from a disease and the vaccine could
result in 50 000 adverse reactions
we we have to choose the least amount of
damage so we'll encourage people to get
the vaccines and I I understand that it
is quite utilitarian but I can't pretend
to have the answers for people other
than but you see that with children the
mortality rate is far is lower than the
incidence rate of react of reaction
reported by various but I mean obviously
mortality is worst case outcome but
pericada this myocarditis is and so on
is very serious so I mean obviously we
sit here we we second guess and we
armchair a lot of these
um Health experts but when you when you
look at you know the the problem is and
you see with any kind of information
system it reminds me of a kind of like a
Hayek versus Kane sort of argument when
you have decentralized sort of um you
know decision makers uh you know uh we
have doctors who can assess individual
health risks and
um and just have that patient-centric
care that we're so used to in the United
States uh where we have a consumer model
of of medicine provision right um
you know that is is has tended to serve
the United States people very well we
have lower we have we have Superior
cancer treatment we have some of the
most advanced
um medical centers in the world
um but what we're seeing right now is a
more socialized medicine approach where
bureaucrats who are not teaching are
treating everyone in American society as
if they're a homogeneous group
um and we're all likely to have a
serious uh reaction to covid when or the
Delta variant which is predominant in
the United States right now and is much
weaker and less less deadly
statistically is treating us as if we're
all at equal risk this is not the way
the United States medicine has been
practiced uh and we've always relied on
our doctors to make the best judgments
there's a few exceptions in a smallpox
uh for example uh you know led to you
know mandates for vaccines so it isn't
the first time it's ever happened in
this country by the way
um but but what we see with the with the
vaccines is they just rolled out so fast
with the warp speed and you know there's
a lot of conflicting information we're
in the information age now and it's
we're getting pulled in different
directions it's undermining trust for a
lot of people and they're projecting
Their Fear of the vaccine uh into their
General distrust of the establishment
you know the people who have problems
with the election and the people who
have a problem with the vaccine there's
likely to be a very large overlap
however it isn't the largest reticent
group in the United States
demographically it's African Americans
followed by Hispanics who which Asians
seem to be the most likely to go the you
know what uh among educated the largest
uh phds yeah yeah it's interesting
strange I I ultimately think there's
been a lot of people because I always
say talk to your doctor and then I get
the typical response from people is like
doctor my doctor doesn't know anything
or otherwise and I'm like you have a bad
doctor you know what I mean like uh man
I've been prescribed stuff in the past I
don't even know what it is you know when
you when I got like I injured my knee
they gave me some kind of steroid you
get for like an attendant inflammation
and damage or whatever I'm like I don't
know what this is thanks Doc patch me up
and send me on my way doctor hands me a
bunch of things like here you go take
this stuff uh I don't know I'm pregnant
alone or something prednisone Portico
steroids yes yeah so I I had damage
what's the what is it meninskis meniscus
meniscus yeah yeah I fell from like a
seven foot quarter pipe to the deck dude
I was just screwed I was cruising I was
trying to do a rock and roll just
cruising around I hung up it happens you
know when the front wheels hit it and I
go to the doctor and he's like here you
go and he literally pulled out a bunch
of his little packets and he's like
you're good that's enough and he was
like he gave me the prescription he gave
me the regimen or whatever and I'm like
I don't know what it is I'm gonna take
it if you don't trust your doctor you
need to find a doctor you trust and see
if the crazy thing about it is yeah
people can be political you might go to
a doctor and he's got like a Biden flag
and he's waving in front of you then go
find it guys get the Trump flag and ask
him I was a doctor I don't know if I
find a doctor you trust but yeah you're
right I think this weird thing happened
with it's it's very tribalist where
there's a big overlap between people who
don't trust the establishment and also
our skeptical of vaccines
but it's isn't it interesting how it's
switched with the election so this is
fascinating the the polling data shows
that Democrats felt the economy was bad
but right when Joe Biden got elected
they felt the economy was good like come
on and of course we had not based on
medicine and other Democrats were
throwing shade on the vaccine before the
election and then when Joe Biden's
election no the vaccines find everybody
has to get it it's a really weird it's a
weird flip yeah so I can understand you
know people uh here's the only thing I
can understand is I went and talked to
my doctor my doctor said X like right on
that's that's all other than that
basing your view of your health off of
political tribalism I think is really a
bad idea like yo go for a walk man turn
Twitter off thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time